[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue nous allons comme chaque soir
débriefer l'actualité pour donner des
opinions des points de vue nous
l'espérons divergent sur ce qui s'est
passé dans les dernières heures nous
commencerons bien sûr par revenir sur
l'interview donnée par le président de
la république
hier soir c'était chez nos confrères de
tf1 et lci at il réussi à gommer son
image de président des riches alors même
qu' ils affirment ses positions sur un
certain nombre de sujets des réformes
des lois sociales elyes f
nous allons en reparler nous reviendrons
sur un point spécifiquement abordé par
le président de la république sur les
expulsions des immigrés clandestins
le président a promis que toutes celles
et ceux qui étaient en situation
irrégulière et qui commettraient des
délits seraient systématiquement
expulsés at il les moyens de le faire
nous y reviendrons et puis l'homme que
vous voyez à l'écran vous allez
apprendre à le connaître il s'appelle
sebastian course c'est le chef du parti
chrétien démocrate autrichien et il a
gagné assez largement les élections
législatives hier s'apprête à former
probablement une coalition avec
l'extrême droite autrichienne nous
reviendrons aussi sur le tweet du
week-end balances ton port un appel a
dénoncé sur twitter les auteurs de
harcèlement marlène schiappa les
secrétaires d'état pour l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes accompagne ce
mouvement et promet notamment une loi
sur le harcèlement de rue
bonsoir nos quatre invités qui ont
accepté de participer à cette émission
lucile schmid
vous êtes c'est la co présidente de la
fondation verte européenne
vous avez été élu régional pour le parti
socialiste auquel vous n'appartenez plus
aujourd'hui et vous avez publié en 2016
la france résiste tel à l'écologie
bonsoir alexandre malafaye vous êtes le
président du think tank sinopia vous
d'être aussi chroniqueur chez nos
confrères de l'opinion et on vous entend
régulièrement à rtl notamment quand il
s'agit de refaire le monde
bonsoir anne fulda vous êtes journaliste
politique au figaro vous avez signé
notamment un grand portrait dans le
dernier numéro d'almaviva sur brigitte
macron mais dans la famille macron vous
connaissez aussi bien emmanuel puisque
vous êtes l'auteur de la biographie de
référence sur le président de la
république emmanuel macron un jeune
homme si parfait qui a été publié chez
plon et bonsoir alexandre 2 vecchio vous
êtes journaliste
la rubrique débats et opinions du figaro
vous êtes en charge du figaro vox votre
dernier livre qu'il fait ou six premiers
d'ailleurs tout c'était votre dernier
livre à ce jour alors c'était les
nouveaux enfants du siècle paru l'année
dernière aux éditions du cerf nous
allons évidemment parler pour commencer
de 2 emmanuel macron est ce qu'il est
devenu hier le président des parrish
c'est à dire est ce que il a voulu
s'adresser à cette france qui a priori
et est circonspecte par rapport à ces à
ces réformes en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que il est droit dans ses
bottes
je pensais que personne mieux que le
figaro ne pouvait critiquer l'impôt sur
la fortune
eh bien je dois avouer que nous avons
trouvé notre m regardez on est dans la
grande hypocrisie française c'est une
taxe pour millionnaires mais pas pour
milliardaires mais surtout quel était le
résultat de la sf tel qu'on l'avait
celles et ceux qui étaient en train de
réussir partait et on a perdu beaucoup
de talent et beaucoup de gens qui
commençait à réussir ou qui fortune
faite une fois qu'ils vendaient leur
entreprise allait profiter de leur
fortune ailleurs bon et beaucoup de gens
qui avaient gagné beaucoup d'argent ne
le paye et pas par ces montages
financiers dont je parle et donc elle
n'est pas vraiment juste mais si jamais
il faut reconnaître cette qualité à
emmanuel macron c'est que il assume ses
choix et compris le plus symbolique
d'entre eux c'est à dire la suppression
de l'impôt sur la fortune
oui c'est vrai qu'il assume ses choix il
a un côté très pédagogue même moi ce que
je voulais dire c'est que ce qui m'a
marqué c'est qu'il a dit qu'on était un
pays où il y avait des passions tristes
et de l' envie de la jalousie
à partir de là j'ai pris vous avez des
riches oui vis-à-vis des riches il a dit
pour ça je pense qu'il ya un vrai sujet
sur la façon dont sans doute emmanuel
macron ne sais pas où placer la question
de l'argent et dont il n'est pas
conscient du fait que dans notre société
la façon dont l'argent manque pour les
services publics pour un certain nombre
de projets pour lorsqu'on est dans une
situation à peu précaire donc son
plaidoyer il est remarquable et j'allais
dire il aurait pu gagner le concours
d'éloquence à sciences po
mais le sujet s'est ensuite quand on est
président de la république comment
est-ce qu'on s'adresse à l'ensemble de
la société en prenant en considération
le fait que l'argent manque sans doute
dans des secteurs très stratégie que
j'ai déjà dit ici mais que supprimer 3
milliards et demi d'argent public parce
qu'on supprime l'impôt sur la fortune
moi je pense que c'est pas que c'est pas
anodin donc traiter la question de
l'argent comme si
quelque part elle était juste une
question de jalousie sociale ça me
dérange et donc moi je pense qu'il n'est
pas devenu le président je réponds à
votre question que vous ne m'avez pas
posée mais le président d parrish
d'ailleurs les pas riches parce que
c'est cesser les classes moyennes et les
classes moyennes supérieures les parrish
du tout il n'est pas devenu le présent
les paris du tout mais moi par exemple
je suis une peut-être une parrish
moyenne n'est pas devenu mon président
après cette intervention j'ai considéré
que la question de l'argent il semblait
en avoir une vision un petit peu de
d'enfants gâtés
tu vas vous êtes vous avez étudié de
près la carrière professionnelle
emmanuel macron ses convictions aussi il
a toujours eu ce rapport décomplexé à
l'argent
écoutez oui visiblement enfin surtout je
pense qu'il a évidemment été marqué par
son passage à la banque rothschild où il
s'est retrouvé confronté à des personnes
en fin et à faire des deals qui qui
mettait en cause des milliards d'euros
donc mais et il a toujours eu
effectivement une relation assez directe
face à l'argent il a su aussi ce qu'il a
répété d'ailleurs quand il est passé à
l'elysée dire voilà j'ai voulu de
l'argent pour acquérir ma liberté
mais je sais aussi dire renoncer à un
salaire qui était plus que qu'honorable
pour faire ceux d'orange oxo j'ai
vraiment envie de faire c'est à dire de
la politique donc oui il a toujours eu
une relation assez assez clair face à
l'argent cela dit c'est vrai que je suis
assez d'accord
son explication a été clair assez
limpide il a dit des choses qui avait
besoin d'être dites concernant la
justification de cette suppression de
l'impôt sur la fortune
néanmoins sa façon de parler ne
s'adresse pas à tout le monde c'est il
chez plus qui je crois que c'est brice
hortefeux qui a dit qu'il ya une une
espèce de manière de s'adresser aux
élites et il ya un peu de ça non pas que
je veuille dire que parler de façon
intelligente c'est parler aux élites
mais il ya quelque chose dans le ton qui
fait qu'effectivement il ne s'adresse
pas à tout le monde est d'accord avec ça
avec son mari pascal a priori quand on
parle sur tf1 à 10 millions de personnes
il faut mieux parler au peuple qu'à
l'élite si l'on se trompe de médias
alors c'est vrai qu'il a une façon de
parler qui
sophistiqué qui est structuré qui peut à
un moment donné quand il est vrai un peu
longue peut-être perdre quelques
auditeurs dans cela dit fais un effort
de pédagogie qu'il faut souligner et on
est quand même sur des sujets complexes
et on peut pas toujours tout résumé avec
une ou deux phrases et est une formule
choc après j'ai trouvé qu'il avait
beaucoup insisté sur le fait qu'ils se
présentaient comme étant le président de
tous les français il a insisté là-dessus
bon après il insiste en disant aussi
qu'il a un mandat pour vous pourrez
revenir sur la valeur effectivement de
son élection sur un plan de la
légitimité quand au programme sais mais
c'est pas le sujet de ce soir
en revanche effectivement le fait qu'ils
insistent sur le fait je suis présente
tous les français fait que derrière il
peut dérouler un raisonnement kelly je
suis présent tous les français mais ça
peut dire que je ne ferais rien donc
forcément obligé de faire des choix et
j'assume ces choix et là il va au bout
de sa logique est de cette manière là y
compris sur les questions de l'usf
il a raison alors est-ce qu'il a raison
de le supprimer les sur une
partiellement de faire une exception
pour les yachts et autres ça c'est des
débats là encore sur laquelle qui ne
sont pas tranchés et ça devrait apporter
un drap le cas échéant le moment venu de
trancher
en revanche il a quand même avec cette
étiquette de présent des riches pour le
coup qui n'a pas choisi de se voir
accoler mais qui c'est a collé assez
naturellement compte tenu des positions
qu'il a prises ou des silences qui l'a
laissée qui ont laissé finances envahir
cette baisse de bruit qui lui colle
maintenant effectivement très fortement
à la peau eh bien il est un peu dans la
même logique du piège que celui que
françois hollande s'est tendu tout seul
avec son courbe de sa courbe du chômage
et si d'ici 2022 les paris des mieux ma
chronique sur des paris libéraux qui
sont des paris de relance par la
croissance de relance par
l'investissement
si c'était si c'est paris ne fonctionne
pas que en 2022 il n'ya pas peut-être
plus de riches mais surtout moins de
peau est moins de chômeurs pour le coup
il aura vraiment beaucoup de mal à se
départir de cette volonté d'avoir bâti
une france qui a accentué les fractures
les périphéries et les difficultés des
plus faibles au profit de ceux qui
finalement avait déjà ils vont peut-être
se retrouver favoriser ça peut ne pas
marcher le pari que je crois qui est
effectivement possible de réussir c'est
justement c'est le pari inverse c'est à
dire ça va sa théorie des premiers de
cordée peut fonctionner mais si elle ne
marche pas parce que la nature humaine
est aussi ce qu elle est il n'y a
parfois pas toujours très généreuse art
partagé et bien effectivement ça peut
lui vraiment lui collé collé aux basques
si je puis dire
alexandre a vécu est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cathy qui nous dit
emmanuel macron s'est présenté pour
représenter le peuple et non une
certaine catégorie de personnes
or il flatte l'élite maintenant
et je suis pas sûr qu'il s'est présenté
pour représenter le peuple si bien sûr
quand on est président de la république
on est censé représenter tout le monde
mais je crois que c'était dans la
philosophie macro nist et que ce à quoi
on a assisté à l'elysée hier c'était un
cours de philosophie et macro nié je
crois qu'il croit à une société de
l'individu en fait c'est marrant parce
qu'il y avait effectivement sur sa
tapisserie liberté égalité fraternité en
énorme mais c'est peut-être pour combler
voilà le mot qui avait dans son discours
et s'adressait uniquement aux individus
effectivement est pas tous les français
avec cette idée de la réussite par
l'argent et que cette réussite par
l'argent de quelques-uns entraînerait
forcément forcément les autres dans
l'idée de la corde et il ya aussi l'idée
de tirer une corde tirer un peu ce qui
serait déroulé si on est mauvais esprit
on peut prendre comme ça et penser que
c'est ça que c'est sa vision des choses
donc effectivement quelque chose d'assez
inégalitaire et à mon avis sur le plan
purement économique d'adhérents parce
qu'en réalité la suppression de l'isf
pour les yachts et les ferrari
je ne crois pas une seconde que ça va se
retrouver dans l'économie réelle ils
vont faire quoi ils vont acheter 10 audi
ferrari est ce que c'est idiot tu
essaies ferrari sont fabriqués en france
je ne suis pas sûr et dont le même temps
ils taxent les français aisés c'était
dans le dans le figaro les classes
moyennes un peu supérieure qui elle
consomme et font l'économie réelle donc
jeudi
en plus d'avoir une vision de super
manager je crois plutôt que de président
de la république
je pense que c'est inefficace
économiquement et là on le verra dans
deux ans j'espère me tromper parce que
j'aime mon pays mais je crois pas du
tout à la théorie du ruissellement
alors nicolas de 10 il n'a pas parlé des
contrats aidés qui ont été supprimés
c'est une honte et sylvie il dit qu'il
vient de province il reste un fils de
riche donc une tonalité assez critique
sur les dossiers des internautes qui
nous suivent je voudrais vous proposer
un deuxième extrait de l'intervention du
président de la république hier il
parlait de la protection des plus
faibles et en fait il en a une vision
qui est personnel et qui est assez
original dans le discours ambiant qui
consiste à dire
ma façon de protéger les gens c'est de
les aider à s'adapter
ce n'est pas de les protéger contre le
changement au contraire regardez je veux
que en même temps qu'on libère on
protège et l'esprit de ces réformes
c'est bien ce couple libéré protégés et
les garanties effectives pour reprendre
le beau mot de la philosophe simone weil
c'est non pas d'aller expliquer aux gens
qu'ils ont des droits dans votre tirage
des droits dont ils ne verront jamais la
couleur
c'est de leur dire la société change ne
vais pas vous pour vous proposer de vous
protéger contre la société ou son
changement je vais vous proposer de vous
armer pour trouver une place dans cette
société qui joue c'est vrai que c'est
séduisons c'est vrai que à priori c'est
le discours de la raison quand on les
écoute objectivement c'est vrai on est
vraiment d'ouvert banque après c'est
vrai mais nous sommes en france nous
sommes dans un pays latin catholique de
tradition catholique et où c'est vrai
que l'argent aux religieux revient à ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur sur
l'argent c'est 7,7 cette manière de
pointer du doigt les plus tôt dans le
discours les gens qui sont jaloux l'envi
en fait c'est j'ai entendu pas mal de il
ya des grands patrons qui ont ce
discours très souvent qu'ils disent oui
en france quelqu'un comme bernard ne
regrette par exemple qu'en france si on
on le on interpelle c'est pas
obligatoirement pour le féliciter comme
aux états unis un grand patron ou là
c'est vrai qu'aux états unis les grands
patrons sont sont félicités pour leur
réussite il ya de ça donc
son discours est quand même intéressant
parce que c'est le discours de la
réalité mais c'est un discours à forte
connotation anglo-saxonne libéral et
c'est vrai que la france reste la france
quoi est-ce que ce qu'il fallait il faut
pas adapté ce discours à la france être
faire il a été pédagogue clair mais
c'est terrible à dire mais ce qu'il faut
pas être un petit peu démago le
sèche-cheveux ça vous fait sursauter
quand quand le président bédié je suis
pas là pour défendre des droits et je
sais que je suis là gauchistes du
plateau mais
liberté de parole je n'ai pas
intéressant la caution de rien j'ai
beaucoup aimé cette intervention cette
partie de l'intervention des manuels mac
ne s'est pas du tout pour être à contre
emploi je le dis je pense que la façon
dont il le sujet de l'emploi et de la
formation est une question fondamentale
est que on sait bien qu'il ya différents
rapports qui ont dit que par exemple on
connaît pas 80 % de l'emploi de type de
métier qu'on aura d'ici 30 ans donc
quelque part là il a une vision après le
sujet qui me frappe c'est l'extrême
abstraction de son discours et je suis
pas en train de dire qu'un président de
la république doit forcément mettre
toujours les mains dans le cambouis des
mots avec des mots très concret mais
hydro déroula système remarquable
logique logiquement mais qui ne
fonctionne pas qui n'a jamais fonctionné
depuis 50 ans donc articulé l'emploi et
la formation amener les gens à changer
leur dire qu'ils vont avoir un autre
emploi leur dire qu'on va leur consacrer
de l'argent alors que d'habitude c'est
les plus qualifiés qui bénéficient de la
formation tout ça est très bon encore
faudrait-il qu'on le croit et en ce sens
je suis pas sûr que aujourd'hui sur le
plan budgétaire sur le plan des choix
politiques
j'entendais ce que vous disiez sur le
fait que les choix sont très libéraux je
pense que les choix de principe sont
très intéressantes sur l'emploi et la
formation mais et la reconversion par
exemple sur l'écologie nicolas hulot
porte des contrats de transition
écologique on va reconvertir des sites
industriels en formant les écoles la
rigueur d'ailleurs on en n'a pas du tout
parlé mais il faut bien dire une chose
c'est que les journalistes n'ont pas
incité le président de la république en
parler il est assez rare qu'il s'auto
saisir du sujet comme j'ai très
longtemps sans réponse sauf si nicolas
hulot est dans la pièce mais bon donc le
sujet c'est plutôt comment est-ce qu'il
va passer à part non la feuille de route
j'ai employé des termes un peu techno
mais il est tellement peu péquenots
danse qui dit qu' on se demande si ça va
déboucher sur quelque chose ou sur un
nouveau discours dans six mois altama la
fire cela nous dit ce que dit macron
fonctionne pour les gens en pleine forme
mais les faibles ils les oublient c'est
ce qu'on reproche à son discours
là encore lui se rebondir et en disant
je développe la théorie de la cordée est
donc évidemment ceux qui réussissent
tireront les autres mais pensez quoi
et j'en pense que j'en pense qu'en fait
d'abord sur sur son court discours du
congrès de versailles il avait déjà
cessé
si je puis dire ses préoccupations y
compris par rapport à l'argent et ça
fait dix ans que nicolas sarkozy aussi
en son temps avait essayé réconcilier de
france est claire
ça faisait partie des sujets de fond
parce qu'il ya malgré tout il ya un
problème de rapport à la réussite qui
est compliqué qui vient de loin et qui
doit être mon avis pris quelque part
dans le débat pour essayer de voir de
faire une phase de pédagogie positif de
réconcilier un peu les gens les uns avec
les autres
quand même parce que voilà on peut pas
être que les adversaires des uns
vis-à-vis des autres on peut pas bâtir
une nation en divisant son peuple et lui
ce qu'il est 16h au contraire c'est de
ne pas faire ça mais c'est pas facile
parce que les signaux envoyés sont pas
non plus très très très simple à lire
cela dit sur l' approche purement
économique son discours c'est quoi c'est
à dire le monde est comme il est il faut
être pragmatique il faut adapter notre
économie peut-être pas fait qu'ils ont
offert plusieurs riches mais en tout cas
pour se préparer à un monde qui change
de plus en plus et la lecture et les
simples c'est à dire regardez depuis 30
ans il ya de moins en moins de cdd cdi
il ya plus en plus de cdd il ya plus en
plus d'intérim il ya plus en plus de
contrôles seront preneurs dire qu 1,2
million contre entrepreneurs en france
aujourd'hui donc c'est des données qui
sont quand même assez importante
donc le marché de l'emploi stable a duré
avis se déstructure la fonction publique
donc trop l'exemple il ya de plus en
plus de co2 de contrat le contrat court
2 et n'ont pas d'emploi à vie dans la
fonction publique donc tout ça doit être
pris en considération et donc de fait il
faut préparer les parcours alors moi
j'aurais bien aimé que cette démarche
d'accompagnement du changement il la
mène dès le départ en sur le volet
sécurité en même temps que le volet
flexibilité je pense que ça aurait
davantage de clarté de pertinence de la
démarche
mais sur le fond le monde est ce qu'il
est et la déstructuration du marché du
travail doit être véritable plan conclu
b risation c'est une réalité mais du
coup comme nous dit georges qui ironise
macro à raison la société change
les pauvres sont toujours plus pauvres
et les riches toujours plus riches
alexander et que ce n'est pas
complètement vrai en tout cas en france
où le système de redistribution marche
bien mais on a le sentiment général on
ne serait-ce qu'en gardant nos
internautes même si même si ça n'est pas
un sondage que la petite musique sur le
président des riches à l'ap a été
complètement arrêté hier
non parce qu' effectivement il y avait
une forme d'assurance on a eu quand même
une heure et demie de
d'auto satisfaction de la part des
manuels ma cour et qui sur le plan des
annonces n'a rien lâché
moi ce qui me ce qui me trouve je suis
pas du tout pour une société de
l'assistanat ou donnera le revenu
universel aux gens où le rsa et puis se
débrouiller à chaud je trouve que c'est
malsain et qu'il faut effectivement
aider les gens à s'en sortir et avoir du
travail mais je crois que je crois pas
que macro une suprême de la bonne
manière puisqu'il est favorable en fait
à une économie hors sol et c'est pas ton
il propose pas tant aux gens d'avoir du
travail que de devenir tous des nomades
ubs et je crois que c'est beaucoup plus
destructeur que créateur ben économie or
seul c'est une économie par exemple où
le patrimoine est considéré comme une
rampe puisque sur les sl c'est
symptomatique c'est ce qui va taxer et
pas les yachts et les ferrari c'est une
france où on considère que les ouvriers
attachés à leur usine [ __ ] le bordel
je crois que dans son inconscient ou
même très consciemment emmanuel macron
on rêve d'une france aux usines parce
qu'ils pensent que c'est la modernité
que désarmant c'est les startups que le
nouveau monde s'est libéré ben moi je
m'inscris en faux sur ce diagnostic
je crois par exemple que l'allemagne
dont on nous rebat les oreilles ça
qu'ils ont un modèle performant mais
c'est un modèle qui est fondée sur
l'industrie sur un réseau de pme donc je
crois qu'il faut que la france
réfléchissent à l'investissement
productif et là je ne vois rien et donc
je pense que c'est encore une fois non
seulement sa politique est injuste mais
elle est inefficace et elle reviendra si
on suit cette évolution dans les
prochaines années justement au revenu
universel pour les plus faibles auquel
on fera l'aumône et des super riches
donc des écarts à mon avis qui ne sont
pas simples pour une société qui crée
une société extrêmement fracture donc si
benoît hamon nous écoute ça n'est pas
perdu le revenu universel à un grand
avenir à présent 2022 ailleurs macro et
hésité à proposer le revenu universel il
s'est dit que c'était sans doute pour
risqué mais c'était dans sa tête et
c'est une thèse défendue par l'est les
ultralibéraux par le capitalisme
californien de la silicon valley et
enfin ce qui moi ce qui me frappe en
écoutant c'est que maintenant quand on
compare emmanuel macron à quelqu'un on
compare à nicolas sarkozy on compare
jamais à françois mitterrand ni au
général de gaulle et donc je vous
rappelle quand même que ce n'était pas
une d1 d3 président qu'il avait cité
pendant la campagne qui étaient ses
modèles donc il faut qu'il fasse
attention à ne pas perdre de vue les
modèles théoriques
parce que aujourd'hui qu'on compare à
nicolas sarkozy n'est pas forcément une
très bonne chose et je vous de cette
réaction de nicolas
j'ai 58 ans mon contrat aidé est
terminée à cause de macron on se
souvient que le président publique a
annoncé qu effectivement les contrats
aidés serait dramatiquement restreint je
voudrais soumettre à votre réflexion la
question du figaro d'aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron vous at il convaincu et
bien aux dernières nouvelles on en était
à 52 74 % de oui et 49 26 % de non anne
fulda est-ce que c'était un coup pour
rien finalement cette interview d'hier
puisque apparemment ça laisse les
français
perplexe il ya d'ailleurs un rallye qui
nous dit au final la pensée complexe la
pensée complexe laisse perplexe non je
pense pas que c'était un coup pour rien
parce que je trouve qu'il a quand même
assez bien expliqué ce qu'il ce qu'il
voulait faire
en revanche n'est pas assez concret pas
assez liées au terrain c'est à dire que
quand il prend une mesure quand il
décide de réformer la csf pour en faire
un impôt qui permet d'orienter les
pattes vers l'investissement dans les
entreprises
c'est quelque chose qu'il aurait dû
illustré je trouve et je trouve qu'il
aurait dû faire encore plus de pédagogie
sur sur les entreprises sur l'importance
des entreprises en france les
entreprises n'étant pas que les grandes
entreprises c'est à dire que il un peu
oublier aux sites où se tissent tissu
français qui est constituée d'énormément
de pme qui ont qui ont beaucoup
d'importance et qui pour certaines font
participe vraiment à la richesse de la
france et je trouve qu'il aurait dû plus
illustre est effectivement ça sent son
discours d'exemples très concrets
voilà mais je trouve que c'est un coup
pour rien parce que je trouve que par
exemple il sa théorie deux premiers de
cordée elle
bon elle elle sera retenue alors après
est ce que commencent à se traduit
concrètement on verra mais il a expliqué
il avait besoin de parler aux français
il n'avait pas fait depuis
finalement il avait fait que à travers
une interview au point qu'ils étaient là
aussi
quand même réservé à un public assez
restreint et qui était une interview
assez élitiste
donc c'est pas un coup pour rien je suis
pas d'accord mais il faut compléter
d'accord alors il ya eu permettre je
voudrais juste rajouter pour dire que je
pense que c'est non seulement pas un
coup pour rien je pense que c'est très
utile puisque qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
d'accord avec la politique est menée par
un gouvernement par un exécutif en a
besoin de comprendre ce qui se passe on
a besoin d'éclairage et comme en plus on
a un débat public qui a tendance à
déraper assez facilement sur des sujets
on va dire qu'ils sont futiles ou
pouvoir parfois sur des éléments de
provocation sur laquelle on pourrait
s'arrêter dans tout cas d'en faire
autant je pense que typiquement et
emmanuel à caen il participe lui même
quand il fait qu'ils vivent ils agitent
ces petites phrases maladroites depuis
l'étranger et qu'on avant pass 2 jours à
s'intéresser aux fainéants
on met pas le niveau public ou bon
niveau et là il le fait après on déballe
à ce soit en débat sur le fond sur ces
sur les grandes orientations et ça c'est
bien c'est ce dont la france a besoin
ok alors il ya annie qui nous dit il n'a
rien dit sur l'immigration et bien si
cherradi il en a parlé
quand il a évoqué le cas des situations
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
c'était le cas du terroriste qui a
assassiné deux jeunes femmes à la gare
de marseille il y à il y a dix jours
maintenant
cet homme bien qui est en situation
irrégulière avaient été arrêtés à lui
reprises mais jamais expulsé et bien ça
va changer emmanuel macron l'a promis je
veux être ici intraitable toutes celles
et ceux qui étant étrangers en situation
irrégulière commettent un acte
délictueux quels qu'ils soient seront
expulsés et je souhaite qu'on prenne
toutes les dispositions de caen
d'organisation dès les prochains jours
prendront ces dispositions
d'organisation mais ça veut dire aussi
qu'on doit être plus efficaces dans nos
politique de reconduite alex auld avec
qui on a envie de dire il serait temps
parce qu'on sait que jusqu'à présent les
mesures de reconduite à la frontière
sont sont quasiment jamais suivies
d'effet oui d'ailleurs ce qu'il dit est
quand même très très intéressant parce
qu'il parle d'expulser ceux qui ont plus
de commettre a lancé plus considérée
comme un délit mais qui sont d'une
certaine manière
hors la loi en étant
clan des stars commettent un délit par
dessus le marché donc cela il va les
expulser mais il faudrait faire
appliquer les règles de l'état de droit
il faudrait effectivement reconduire
tous ceux qui doivent être reconduits je
n'ai pas le chiffre exact mais on sait
que ça se chiffre en centaines de
milliers et que 90% des étrangers en
situation irrégulière aujourd'hui ne
sont pas encombrés donc ça c'est un vrai
dysfonctionnement de l'état s'il
parvenait à y remédier et ce jusqu'à une
c'est parce qu'ils proposent de faire il
propose simplement d'expulser encore une
fois ceux qui ont commis un délit mais
si le il rendait la machine un peu plus
efficace ce serait bien mais on se
demande pourquoi depuis des dizaines
d'années cette machine n'est pas
efficace il ya le droit européen il ya
un certain nombre de choses qui à mon
avis il faudrait simplifier puisque
sinon la démocratie c'est quand même les
politiques et c'est pas les juger
l'administration tu sais je suis moi je
suis je suis gêné par le raisonnement
parce que je trouve que en un raccourci
saisissant en fait chacun d'entre nous
voit le contexte que deux femmes ont été
assassinées et donc assimile le fait de
reconduire à la frontière d'expulser un
clandestins délinquants avec le fait de
lutter contre le terrorisme et pour moi
ce n'est pas du tout la même chose
c'est-à-dire que je crois que lutter
efficacement contre le terrorisme ce
n'est pas reconduire à la frontière et
expulser les clandestins délinquants
donc première chose je n'accepte pas la
manière dont on fait ce raccourci
deuxièmement je pense qu'on peut pas
assimiler le fait de commettre un délit
et le fait d' assassiner je tiens à le
dire
je pense que c'est un problème de
principe et troisièmement je pense qu'on
peut pas assimiler les étrangers les
terroristes donc je suis gêné sur trois
trois éléments principe puis la deuxième
chose là je rejoins alexandre des
vecchio sur les principes nous différons
fortement mais sur sur ce sujet je pense
qu'il est absolument impossible
d'expulser tous les clandestins en
france c'est quelque chose je crois pas
que l'administration française est en
vie que les clandestins baisse en france
3 qui a un côté inextricable sur le plan
juridique notamment d'un certain nombre
de situations familiales lorsqu'on a des
enfants français
on ne peut pas être expulsé c'est ce
qu'on appelle et nini c'est à dire
qu'ils sont ni expulsables ni
régularisables et ce à tous les présents
de la république font semblant que ce
soit très simple alors que ils savent
pertinemment
manque cet inextricable donc il ya un
sujet sur le fait de ne pas engager trop
fortement la crédibilité du président
macron sur une question sur lequel il ne
pourra pas expulsés on le sait déjà
tous ceux qui sont clandestins en france
ça peut être un point de fragilité ça
pour alexandre macron pour emmanuel
babeau avec l'armada est 7e cette
impuissance dont parlait lui six l'idée
que le prison un public reconnaît
quasiment c'est ce que les français vont
pas lui reprocher bien sûr que si elle
lui reprocheront parce que les chiffres
lui donnerons pas raison il n'y arrivera
pas vous l'avez vous l'avez très bien
dit là encore on est sur une dérive
historique c'est à dire que on a on a
conçu des dispositifs à une époque où le
monde n'était pas devenu ce qu'il est
devenu
et on a été très très généreux d'une
certaine façon et c'est sans doute très
bien d'être très généreux avec cette
idée de pouvoir ouvrir deux pour
accueillir et on a même fait sauter en
2012 je crois on descend 2012 le fait
que le séjour illégal et était est et
n'est plus un délit
donc on peut rentrer ça c'est un délit
se fait reprendre moment on passe la
frontière c'est un délit mais finalement
séjourner en france manière illégale
c'est plus un délit donc automatiquement
ça vous oblige ça vous amène pas sortir
du pays
bon est ce que c'est bien ce que c'est
bien moralement on peut se poser la
question mais moralement c'est pas mal
d'accueillir sauf qu'entre temps il ya
eu toute une série de crises y compris
provoquée par la france la libye on a
fait sauter le verrou libyen donc de
fait on a ouvert la méditerranée et et
de fait on a plein de deux malheureux
qui arrivent chez nous la guerre en
syrie n'a échappé à personne et ça
provoque des flux migratoires
considérable et on a des dispositifs qui
ont été conçus à une époque on n'avait
pas imaginé tout ça donc on a un
anachronisme juridiques techniques
légales qui est très compliqué et un
système qui s'appelle l'état de droit
qui nous enferment au nom de l'état de
droit à un moment donné on peut pas
faire n'importe quoi et d'ailleurs ont
fait pas n'importe quoi parce qu'on est
un état de droit qui se veut respectueux
de ça sinon c'est pas un état de droit
ça s'appelle la russie par exemple pour
dire un gros vent en tout cas ça
s'appelle plus bas et à droite elle que
nous on l'a conçu avec des vraies
valeurs et ça pose un vrai sujet
maintenant comment on fait dans la durée
c'est forcément compliqué parce qu'on ne
peut pas continuer à amalgamer sous
prétexte qu'il ya des migrations
tout le monde en pensant que ça va bien
se passer ça ne se passera pas bien dans
la durée si on n'est pas très attentifs
donc il ya un énorme sujets de fond est
par contre prendre des engagements aussi
précis que ce qu'il a fait hier pour le
coup c'est effectivement un risque un
peu vous parliez de 10 à 30 ans il faut
être un peu démago là il est un peu
un foulard en sortez un peu le sens
globalement en retrait sur ce sujet il
est beaucoup moins loquace d'ailleurs
que sur les sujets économiques ou
fiscaux est ce que quand il sait pas ce
que c'est pas une de ses préoccupations
principales l'immigration oui j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas dans ses
dents sont dans ces premiers prix aux
énoncés pas dans ces radars c'est vrai
qu'il a une une culture essentiellement
économique
alors lui dira aussi philosophique et
littéraire mais ces questions là ne le
touche pas
ne l'intéresse pas particulièrement
pendant la campagne on a bien vu ce
n'était pas un sujet qui était
extrêmement présent il a soigneusement
évité comme il a évité les questions
liées à la laïcité
il a été trés il n'a pas fait de vagues
il a très peu abordé le sujet c'est
c'est vrai que son principal prisme
c'est l'économie et c'est vrai que ce
qu'il a dit là sur la nécessité de de
l'expulser et de cette façon de montrer
qui serait intraitable ça on avait
l'impression d'avoir déjà entendu ce
discours un peu de matamore alors que
lorsqu'on regarde les chiffres des
expulsions on a vu elles ont diminué de
16% entre entre 2016 et 2015 donc il ya
un vrai problème ce qui serait
intéressant c'est de voir ce qui va se
passer autour du projet de loi sur
l'immigration que prépare gérard collomb
où il est en train de travailler sur une
allongement de la durée de rétention des
des clandestins en camp de 90 jours à la
place de 45 jours il va y avoir quelques
points comme ça dans le projet de loi
sur l'immigration qu'il faudra
surveiller pour voir si effectivement
ces propos cette manière comme ça de
jouer du matador du tout avec moi ça ne
se passera pas comme ça on expulsera les
les clandestins si ça pourra vraiment
entrer en oeuvre du rhin qui est
beaucoup moins gêné que manuel mâcon
pour parler d'immigration
c'est le probable futur chancelier
autrichien
il s'appelle sebastian course il a donc
remporté avec son parti
chrétien-démocrate les élections hier
soir et il ne cachait pas sa joie à
l'annoncé des résultats
[Applaudissements]
l'autriche c'est pas très loin de la
france
voilà un homme qui remporte assez
largement les élections après avoir été
mis sous affaires étrangères et s'être
avoir bâti sa campagne sur sa capacité à
ça a coupé l'immigration en particulier
celle des qui venait par les balkans il
pourrait faire un accord électoral avec
un parti d'extrême droite afp ho qui lui
même est très très haut ce qu'il a
obtenu presque 26 % quasiment autant que
le les sociaux démocrates
pourquoi est ce que la droite triomphe
en autriche alors qu'en france elle est
en lambeaux je pense que la france et
contra cyclique donald trump a gagné aux
états unis et theresa may triomphe quand
même plus ou mois en angleterre sur fond
de briques cité aujourd'hui on a ce
phénomène là on ne triche donc je pense
qu'on a toujours un décalage de dix ans
quand il y avait un régal et thatcher ou
pouvoir on a même françois mitterrand
aujourd'hui on à emmanuel manquons pas
ce qui est intéressant de voir c'est que
sans doute futur chancelier autrichien à
gagner face à une coalition
gauche-droite finalement enfin c'est une
politique libérale européenne assez
proche de ce que fait emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui donc je pense que emmanuel
macron dans le futur libéra
effectivement un espace pour une droite
protectionnistes régulatrice assez dur
sur les questions d'immigration ça
paraît aujourd'hui leur logique et d'une
certaine manière peut-être que
l'autriche est un laboratoire pour la
droite française de demain accents à la
faille c'est aussi votre point de vue
enfin le front national fait quand même
4 % au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle on peut pas dire que la
droite on va dire dur soit totalement
absent du paysage politique tout de même
après c'est un petit pays l'autriche
donc il ya évidemment un petit pic est
quand même un peu balloté même s'ils
sont neutres au sein de l'otan et sont
pas membres de l'otan
le reste du temps ils sont un peu
ballotté comme vous êtes peu cheap et du
million et demi d'habitants dans un
une énorme système s'appelle l'union
européenne avec un peu plus de 500
millions
forcément votre voix votre capacité à
peser et votre liberté manoeuvre est
forcément un fait que vous êtes un peu
ballotté donc c'est un petit pays il
voit autour de toute une série de
problématiques qui leur posent plein de
problèmes ils ont quand même une
identité alors je mets des guillemets
parce qu'il s'agit pas de dire c'est un
gros mot mais une histoire il une étoile
sur une tradition et une culture et il
voit tout d'un coup qu'il ya des
phénomènes migratoires importants puis
voit les effets rieur les images
projetées de des flux migratoires dans
toute une série de pays et pour le
meetic qu'on a en termes d'intégration
de cohésion les dérives terroristes qui
sont l'apanage de tous petits mais quand
même qu'ils sont là avec des
problématiques de fond en terme de vie
ensemble
forcément ça les préoccupent et de fait
ça alimente un moment donné des fonds de
fonds de réaction d'hier on veut garder
notre destin en main et donc on veut se
donner les moyens d'avoir voilà d'avoir
la capacité à bâtir le futur qu'on veut
bâtir je pense que de la même manière si
on avait dit aux français en 1975 mais
180 la france de 2017 sera celle-là je
sais pas s'il aurait acheté cette france
avec toutes les inégalités qu'on voit
aujourd'hui les difficultés qu'on a les
uns et les autres à vivre ensemble
donc aujourd'hui les autrichiens ils ont
là ils ont ils ont comme des modèles
autour d'eux et forcément ça les fait
réagir
il voit par exemple plus une fumée de
leurs voisins endroits qui ont bâti des
frontières étanches pour arrêter
l'immigration
oui mais il ya aussi une chose qu'on n'a
pas dit c'est que c'est quand même comme
l'allemagne un pays où on gouverne en
coalition et notamment qui avait une
grande coalition au pouvoir et que
courte là ils tirent les marrons du feu
du fait qu'il a fait péter la coalition
c'est à dire que quelque part
la question qu'il faut il faut se poser
c'est pareil sur l'allemagne s'est
acquis bénéficier les coalitions
est ce que c'est à la droite ou à la
gauche en règle générale j'ai plutôt
l'impression de sardaigne ici à la
droite
surtout quand elle prend ligne c'est
l'avis de madame merkel
et c'est la vie je pense de sébastien
courte parce que quand on prend
l'initiative de faire péter la coalition
quelque part apparemment on récupère
plus son électorat du côté de la droite
c'est un point important
j'aurais quand même rappeler que il ya
quelques mois on a eu l'élection de ceux
de ce ver à la présidence mais qui est
pas du tout la présence de la république
française mais il y avait déjà eu un
affrontement entre extrême droite et
alexander van der molen qui
miraculeusement l'avait emporté parce
qu'il y avait une mobilisation
donc c'est quand même un pays où il ya
une structuration d'une extrême droite
puissante qui est prête à exercer le
pouvoir
je suis pas sûr ce soit pareil pour
notre front national et ça c'est un vrai
sujet est ce qu'il vaut mieux une
extrême droite puissante qui est prête à
exercer le pouvoir ou est ce qu'il vaut
mieux le front national moi j'ai pas
envie de choisir entre charybde et
scylla mais en tout cas ces deux ces
deux sujets différents
et ça peut poser d'ailleurs des
questions à la droite française qu'est
ce qu'elle fait lorsqu'elle aura
transformé la gouvernance des
républicains est ce qu'elle fait des
alliances locales
voilà on verra ce qui se passe en
autriche on verra ce qui se passe en
france comme vous le disiez ses huit
millions d'habitants
et ça peut fonctionner à des échelles
régionales en france 28la il ya aussi le
rôle l'importance de l'allemagne 2,2 du
voisin de
ce voisin tellement envahissant parce
qu'il a il a beaucoup fait campagne
contre la politique migratoire de merkel
contre la commission européenne contre
le rôle de la bce il sait pas fan de
quick earth turquie corse quand tu ne
sais pas donc mais c'était une politique
quand même qu'ils allaient à contrario
de celle prônée par par angela merkel
donc c'est intéressant il se positionne
aussi au sein de l'europe comme comme
faisant entendre une petite musique qui
va à l'encontre de celle du géant
allemand
il ya ça aussi dans sa campagne a été
hâtée beaucoup marqué par sa part des
attaques contre la politique menée par
par l'allemagne mais pensez qu'il ya des
leçons à tirer de cette élection pour un
laurent wauquiez au hasard c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué de comparer parce
que c'est vrai qu'on a des systèmes
politiques qui n'ont absolument rien à
voir ce que vient d'être dit c'est que
nous on n'est pas dans des systèmes de
coalition c'est vrai que non là il a
très clairement dit laurent wauquiez
qu'il était hors de question de faire
quelques alliances que ce soit avec le
front national même si tout le monde le
soupçonne de vouloir lancer des
passerelles vers l'extrême droite mais
bon ça semble quand même
non c'est pas c'est quand même pas le
même modèle je pense c'est un type qui
est d'accord avec vous nous dit
l'autriche est historiquement de droite
nationaliste
je lui laisse la responsabilité de cette
appréciation la france n'ont point
d'exclamation iphone que vous êtes
d'accord il n'y a pas de faux pas qui a
pas de situation réplicable d'un pays à
l'autre
non mais je pense qu'il ya une
recomposition globale qui s'observe
partout avec un fait symptomatique c'est
quand même la suisse dont des partis
traditionnels là on a eu encore une
claque pour la social démocratie on a
assisté à la même claque en allemagne
aux etats-unis trump a fait exploser le
parti aux républicains donc je pense
qu'on est dans le tempo si en france
pour françois hollande et en france la
disparition du parti socialiste la très
grande difficulté des républicains donc
je crois qu'on est dans une
recomposition avec un à nouveau clivage
qui se situe mois sur l'axé
droite-gauche que justement sur l'axé
perdant gagnants de la mondialisation je
pense que le rapport à la mondialisation
et le débat du futur et d'une certaine
manière on l'a vu aussi avec le câble de
la catalogne
ce qui est étonnant c'est que pourtant
lotus est un pays prospère qui cloud
sauce le mal est assez bas et donc qui
globalement profitent de la
mondialisation ce qui montre que le
problème n'est pas n'est pas seulement
sociale chose que je voulais dire par
rapport à attribuer à anfield a très
vite sur le nationalisme c'est qu'on
voit bien que le front national
aujourd'hui avec le départ de philippe
o'keefe et les patriotes
il ya aussi une espèce de recomposition
autour du fait national c'est à dire
comment est ce que l'extrême droite
alimente ou pas le patriotisme et que je
pense que chez nous aussi il y aura une
recomposition d'une droite par rapport
aux patriotes qu'il faut avoir en tête
il s'est mis avec you keep au parlement
européen et non plus dans le même groupe
que marine le pen on est là aussi sur
des apparitions de nouvelles familles
politiques
on s'intéresse aux tweets de ce week-end
hashtag balances ton port puis au verset
c'était un appel fait par une
journaliste a dénoncé
les hommes responsables de responsables
coupables de harcèlement
c'est un certain administratif qui a eu
énormément de succès on va revenir sur
les chiffres dans un instant avec
jean-baptiste émergents mais le sujet
est compliqué est-ce qu'il faut
effectivement dénoncer via twitter ce
genre de comportement toute la
complexité du sujet elle est bien
résumée par ces deux séquences d'abord
bruno le maire -ministre de l'économie
et des finances on interroge ce matin
c'est sur france info et il répond
plutôt non écoutés connaissez-vous
aujourd'hui un homme politique dont on
dira dans dix ans nous savions qu'il
était un harceleur le salion non sinon
voulait dénoncer rires non c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué mais la
dénonciation ne fait pas partie de mon
identité politique et après on dit on
s'adapte aussi bien je vous dis
simplement que la dénonciation n'a
jamais fait et ne fera jamais partie de
mon identité poli de toutes les façons
vous ne connaissez pas et de toute façon
je reconnais là il est 8 heures 57 en
est en direct et en fait la polémique
monte très vite comment bruno le maire
refuserait de dénoncer des cas de
harcèlement la pression devient énorme
sur les réseaux sociaux contre le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
et quelques heures plus tard il fait son
mea culpa sur son compte twitter j'ai
réagi home ou de dénonciations que je
n'aime pas et que je n'ai jamais aimé
mais j'aurais dû réagir au problème du
harcèlement sexuel lui même va de soi
que si j'étais au courant de faits de
harcèlement sexuel contre une femme
je serai le premier à les signaler parce
que nous ne pourrons plus longtemps
toléré ce silence qu'il faut libérer la
parole qu'il faut que les femmes
victimes puissent s'exprimer avec tout
le soutien de toute la société et
notamment des responsables politiques et
dans cette séquence quelques secondes
avant
bono le maire s'excuse explicitement
lucile schmid
on est partagé sur ce sujet on se dit on
comprend la volonté des femmes de
dénoncer ce qui se passe avec tous les
risques que ça comporte de dénonciations
anonymes de vengeance
oui je crois si important c'est de voir
aussi d'où est venue la chose c'est à
dire que c'est venu
de ce qui s'est passé autour de
weinstein aux états unis le producteur
le producteur de hollywood qui était
paraît-il le quatrième personnage le
plus puissant de hollywood et qui
maintenant est cité comme le 200ème donc
il ya beaucoup dégringoler et quand il
des prévenus ont la leur et thierry mais
quand il dégringole
on le dénonce donc il ya quelque chose
autour du pouvoir et je pense que on
parle beaucoup de harcèlement sexuel
mais la question c'est la structure du
pouvoir est au fond pourquoi est ce que
certaines femmes sont entrées dans les
filets de cet homme parce qu'elle
voulait un rôle parce que ils les
attirer sous prétexte de leur donner un
rôle et donc qu'il mélangeait le
professionnel la relation pouvoir et la
question sexuelle mais je sais
dissuasive elle même de deux balances
pendant ce temps pendant ce temps fort
bon moi je il ya plusieurs choses qui me
gêne d'abord je pense qu'il ya une chose
qui est positif c'est effectivement de
faire parler des victimes parce que
souvent il ya une inversion c'est à dire
que quelque part la victime se sont
coupables quand elle a subi un
harcèlement violences sexuelles donc ça
c'est bien après je pense pas qu'un
tweet c'est parler et donc la question
que je me pose c'est dans quelle mesure
est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer d'avoir
une parole qui soit à la fois précise
informés et qu'ils soient aussi je sais
pas si j'ai appris le terme de
décomplexer c'est un peu bizarre mais en
tout cas qu'il soit une parole libérée
donc sur cette question de libérer la
parole je pense pas que le tweet soit la
bonne chose après je suis pas du tout
une fanatique des réseaux sociaux je ne
vous cache pas et je pense que ça peut
donner lieu à une sorte de virtualité de
la parole comme souvent les réseaux
sociaux alors que là on est sur des
choses assez graves des choses très
concrètes qui sont arrivés qui entraîne
souvent des traumatismes et donc la
question je me pose c'est la bonne
manière de faire est ce qui m'a marqué
sur weinstein pardon de revenir toujours
aux etats-unis c'est que ça repose sur
deux enquêtes journalistiques
extrêmement documenté d'investigation
pendant plusieurs mois et non pas sur
l'immédiateté du tweet qui entraîne des
phénomènes
moi je trouve assez pathétique que ce
pauvre bruno le maire était obligé de
s'excuser parce que quand il a dit
j'aime pas la dénonciation je peux
comprendre qu'on n'aime pas dénoncer les
gens après on voyait qu'effectivement il
n'avait pas pensé à la gravité du crime
sexuel parce que quelque part le tweak
n'est ce pas n'est pas forcément à
hiérarchiser les choses donc je suis
gêné par le fait que ce soit du tweet je
suis aussi gêné par balances ton porge
concert pas tous les hommes sont des
porcs
et sur le rassasiement sexuelle j'ai
peur que ça m'amène à confondre des
choses très différentes des viols des
questions verbal que la question de la
victime disparaissent derrière
l'emballement du tweet et d'appartenir à
un collectif qui quelque part peut-être
s'adresse plus à certains milieux qu'à
d'autres
par ailleurs jean baptiste émergents du
figaro.fr était avec nous pour ce soir
j'en étais cette campagne balances ton
port à un énorme échos sur les réseaux
sociaux
oui un honneur mais cauet c'est vrai que
ça a commencé aux états unis avec le
hashtag mick harvey weinstein par là qui
arrivait le veut ce débat de société et
donc c'est la journaliste sandra muller
kim journalistes aux états unis qui a
twitté toi aussi raconte en donnant le
nom et les détails un harcèlement sexuel
que tu as connu dans ton boule à partir
de ça on a quand même compté plus de
16000 témoignages qui lui était en
réponse en utilisant le hashtag
justement balances ton port notre
travail avec la un cabinet d'analystes
visibles et a identifié 160 mille tweets
au total avec à peu près 40 9% de tweets
venant d'homme on sait pas si elle ne
sait pas que c'est un sujet féminin mais
effectivement des hommes qui soutiennent
mais aussi qu'ils réagissent les sétois
quelques témoignages qui sont graves et
alarmant on a eu m qui est étudiante à
l'eau à toulouse qui dit dans le métro
un homme de 50 ans qui fixe ma jupe et
qu'il a chez un homme à côté de moi ton
âge on l'aurait vu je l'aurait violée et
il a rigolé choses qui reviennent tout
le temps mode vallereau qui est
journaliste
ce collègue dont tu a dénoncé le
comportement auprès de ton jeu tech de
ton chef avec qui tu as bossé seul le
soit un mois après mirka qui soulève est
aussi là le silence des victimes parce
que ce silence est important soutien
inconditionnel à celle qui twitte mais
aussi à celles qui ne twitte pas qu'ils
n'osent pas enfin ensuite en réaction
donc forcément il ya des réactions qui
réagissent et des hommes aussi qu'ils
prennent la parole kevin bossuyt qu'il
bosse mais qui dit quand on est harcelé
on ne twitte pas on porte plainte donc
ça rejoint ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure mais ça ne chauffe à la plainte
effectivement mais il ya des sujets donc
on à mater qui réagit on savait ce qu on
nous répond quand on porte plainte il ya
pas de preuves on peut rien faire ça a
effectivement la police s est critiqué
sur ce sujet un l'écoutent en
commissariat enfin pour qu'ils violent
qui conclut à ce sujet si les victimes
préfèrent tweeté à halle place de porter
des plaintes
c'est qu'il ya vraiment une grosse
faille dans le système judiciaire dans
ce cas pas de ya pas de bonne solution
où on a compris toutes les dérives de
twitter et en même temps apparemment les
dépôts de plaintes en pas forcément
suivies d'effet
il ya un problème de parce que bon cette
libération de la parole c'est bien mais
c'est en même temps gênant parce que ça
ouvre la porte aussi à des délations des
vengeances enfin bon c'est un peu facile
d'entrer dans une espèce de supermarché
de la dénonciation
on sait pas où s'arrêter néanmoins c'est
vrai que ce qui revient c'est que
lorsque lorsqu'une femme est victime de
telles agressions
ll a rarement un accueil favorable va
tenir dans l'est que dans les
commissariats qui sont débordées voire
parfois goguenard et qu'ils prennent
rarement au sérieux ce genre de pleins
d'eau qu'effectivement il manque une
structure pour pour recueillir 2 et ce
qui est embêtant dans ce mouvement
dénonce t'emporte c'est que c'est
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas encadré judiciairement donc
ses fins et on peut dire tout et
n'importe quoi sur sur twitter et les
réseaux twitter et les réseaux sociaux
alors non pas que ça n'existe pas mais
il faudrait qu'il ait une structure
judiciaire et qui est une structure pour
accueillir effectivement la parole de
femmes qui ont été agressés et en disant
ça j'ai l'impression de relire les mots
qu'ils utilisent et sandrine rousseau
qui lui était horriblement agressé par
park et une voix la wii qui l'autre jour
chez laurent ruquier était en larmes
face à à christine angot qui qui ne
comprenait pas sa position vous parler
de l'absence d'encadrement judiciable
c'est justement pour ça que marlène
schiappa la secrétaire d'état chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
propose de faire une loi alors là
spécifique sur le sur le harcèlement
dans l'espace public elle s'en est
expliqué ce matin sur rtl
l'idée de la verbalisation du
harcèlement de rue c'est effectivement
inquiets du flagrant délit que les
forces de l'ordre puissent verbaliser le
harcèlement de rue et c'est pour ça que
ce sera une priorité de la police de
sécurité quotidienne comme l'a dit hier
le président de la république mais je
pense qu'il est extrêmement important de
dire qu'il ya aussi une valeur
symbolique très forte
regardez à quel point on a libéré la
parole sur le harcèlement de rue avec
quel point on en parle de ce sujet qui
était quand même avoué est avec vous
jusqu'à révéler à la faille on peut
vraiment légiférer sur ce genre de
pratiques
oui je vais revenir un sens pour dire
qu'en tout cas sur sur twitter quand je
vois ce type de dérives
je me dis que le mot hashtag à terme ce
sera ce sera hashtag balance twitter
parce que c'est comme une dérive de fond
qui est très préoccupante là encore sur
ces espèces de libération
invraisemblable de la parole alors bien
sûr sous couvert
trop loin ah oui je trouve ça va non
seulement bien sûr trop loin il faut
avoir une totalement sans pitié sur les
problématiques effectivement d'agression
sexuelle est en fait et bien évidemment
même sur la problématique de l'égalité
hommes femmes avec ce rapport durée
souvent le rapport de prédation
d'autorité de force entre l'homme et la
femme qui s'exerce là dessus il faut
être absolument impitoyable on est bien
d'accord mais ça va très loin il faut
aller mais ça passe par la loi bien sûr
par la justice si on est victime
la réponse de monsieur le maire ce matin
je la comprends à moitié si on est
témoin de quelque chose de délictueuse
on le dénonce évidemment pas sur twitter
mais on le dérange évidemment par les
voies judiciaires et on ne cache rien de
ce genre de choses mais aujourd'hui
c'est partout viola ont aujourd'hui on
s'intéresse activement aux femmes qui
sont victimes d'un homme en l'occurrence
un producteur mais deux en général des
femmes victimes des hommes
mais il ya dans les familles des enfants
qui sont encore très souvent victimes de
leurs parents vous avez quand même
beaucoup de femmes battues qui sont pas
qu'ils peuvent pas s'exprimer tout lu je
crois qu'il y en a une de son qui
meurent tous les ans en france donc on a
des les sujets de les omerta sur toute
une série de sujets comme ça qui sont
encore là le volet web proposés par
mindshare pas c'est intéressant je vois
pas la mise en oeuvre qu'on crée un
délit
si on peut prouver qu'il ya eu un délit
effectivement de 2 voilà de gemal
regarder quelqu'un je vais passer les
faits c'est tout d'un coup bocquet il va
falloir vraiment rentrer dans une
logique de mise en oeuvre qui est là les
là j'ai peur du gadget et qu'on se
trompe en revanche j'aime bien la
démarche de monsieur blanc caire parce
que c'est un problème d'éducation ces
problèmes de fond il faut aller
effectivement au fond des choses on a
parlé tout à l'heure par rapport à
l'écriture inclusive sur lequel je suis
contre par principe parce qu'ils savent
déjà pas écrit ou pas assez bien moi si
en plus on leur ajoute des points
partout ça va pas le faire mais en
revanche pour effectivement comme
exercice pratique pour essayer de dire
il faut qu'on vive ensemble donc
l'inclusion c'est le respect de l'autre
et de rajouter lire écrire compter le
respect ça c'est quelque chose
d'absolument pour le coude essentielle
et c'est ce sera une ou deux générations
pour arriver petit à petit trouver le
bon équilibre pour qu'on ait plus ce
type de comportement prédateur
insupportable alors parmi les gens qui
sont réticents par rapport à ces ce ce
projet d'un d'une loi sur la
verbalisation du harcèlement de rubin il
ya plusieurs chercheurs sociologues qui
ont publié dans libération
si déjà il ya quelques semaines
une tribune qui reprochait à cette
potentielle nouvelle infraction devise
est je cite les jeunes hommes des
classes populaires et racisées alors
racisées ces nouveaux baux probablement
pour dire victimes potentielles de
raciste donc peut-être noirs ou
maghrébins qui subissent déjà plus que
d'autres le contrôle policier et les
violences de forces de l'ordre alex névé
qu est-ce qu il ya un non dit sur ce
sujet là où on peut dire avec toutes les
précautions qui s'imposent qu' il y
avait une culture de la delà du machisme
plus présente chez certaines populations
que chez d'autres bas par exemple pour
c'est que je sais pas si c'est ch chez
certaines populations mais qu'en
banlieue il ya c'est ce que disent elles
en charger culture traditionnelle et de
culture urbaine
il suffit de d'écouter ce que disent les
rappeurs même si je veux pas jouer les
puritains et et ce qui est dans une
chanson et dans une chanson mais j'ai
plus on peut observer tous les jours un
certain nombre de comportements
voilà on se souvient de la journée de la
jupe et je pense que là pour le coup il
ya un véritable problème de société qui
se réglera pas sur twitter l'ailé fille
qui sont confrontés à cette pression
sociale c'est une pression sociale ont
des difficultés à parler parfois dans
leurs familles et etc
je pense pas ta vont aller se raconter
sur twitter donc je pense qu'il faut
quand même garder
effectivement la mesure des choses il
est rare cheese et les choses et puis il
faudrait pas il faut effectivement
dénoncer cette espèce de violences
sexistes même si je n'aime pas le mot
cette violence contre les femmes dans
tous les milieux
effectivement là on dénonce la weinstein
qui ça doit pas être le bouc émissaire
qui est qui et qui cache là où l'arbre
qui cache la forêt c'est effectivement
très facile de s'en prendre à lui parce
qu'il est riche et puissant mais il faut
pas oublier la situation des femmes
effectivement en france dans certains
quartiers ou dans d'autres pays oui mais
moi je trouve que par exemple il avait
un trafic qui avait été remarquable dans
la journée de la jupe elle a pris des
positions il
hier dans le jdd et elle dit bien que
c'est au milieu c'est à dire que le
sujet c'est qu'il faut quand même pas je
pense qu'il sait racialisée je déteste
cette création de mots qui en fait
montre une chambre ou politiquement
correct mal à l'aise mais enfin la
question c'est que ce à travers ces
lieux etc c'est une question de
relations de pouvoir
weinstein c'est ça et d'ailleurs
marlène jobert la mère d'eva green a
raconté comme maire comment elle avait
dû ne pas parler parce que sa fille ne
voulait pas qu'on dénonce weinstein
parce que elle risquait d'avoir subir
une omerta du système donc la question
qu'on doit se poser c'est pas seulement
les individus ses commandes notre
système protège aussi les personnes de
pouvoir
merci beaucoup merci à tous les quatre
et à demain même heure même endroit pour
un prochain point de vue bonsoir raison
[Musique]